- [Instructor] Hello, everyone.
Let's talk about kinetic energy.
Now, kinetic might be an unfamiliar word,
but it just comes from a Greek word
that means of motion,
so kinetic energy is energy from motion.
Any massive object that is in motion then
has kinetic energy, but how much?
First, let's consider some comparisons.
This nice rat family, papa,
mama, brother, and sister
are sitting down to dinner at a long table
passing blocks of cheese back-and-forth.
Papa rat asks for the cheddar cheese
and there are two identical blocks.
Brother rat pushes one and
sister rat pushes the other,
so that the second cheese is traveling
twice as fast as the first cheese.
Which piece of cheddar cheese
do you think has more kinetic energy?
Yes, it's the one going faster.
Now, papa rat doesn't need
both pieces of cheddar,
so he eats one and sends one back,
along with this small piece of Swiss
that weighs half as much
as the piece of cheddar.
Papa rat has better
manners than his children,
so he sends them both
back at the same speed.
Which piece of cheese would you think
has more kinetic energy now?
Yes, the heavier or more massive object,
in this case, the cheddar,
will have more kinetic energy.
Let's make it a little more complicated.
Brother and sister rat are full,
so they send the cheeses
back for mama rat.
Brother rat pushes the
larger piece of cheddar
and sister rat pushes the
smaller piece of Swiss
so that the Swiss is going
twice as fast as the cheddar.
Now, which cheese has more kinetic energy?
In fact, it turns out that it's
the Swiss in this scenario.
Kinetic energy depends
on both mass and speed,
but the dependence on speed is stronger.
This estimation of kinetic energy
can be quantified in an equation
that lets us calculate
kinetic energy exactly.
We said kinetic energy depends on the mass
and the speed, which we'll
write as V for velocity,
so we can start with K E equals M times V.
But we said that it
depends more on the speed,
so the velocity here is actually squared.
This means that if an
object's mass doubles,
its kinetic energy also doubles,
but if its speed doubles,
the kinetic energy actually quadruples.
And there's also a constant factor of 1/2
at the beginning of the equation,
but we won't go into
the details of the math
of deriving this today.
So, this is the equation
for kinetic energy,
1/2 M V squared.
Let's apply this equation
to our cheesy example.
Say the Swiss has a mass of .05 kilograms,
which makes the cheddar's
mass .1 kilograms.
When both cheeses have the same speed,
say two meters per second,
the cheddar's kinetic energy
is 1/2 times .1 kilograms,
times two meters per second
squared, which is .2 Joules.
The Swiss's kinetic energy
is 1/2 times .05 kilograms
times two meters per second
squared, which is .1 Joules,
or half the kinetic energy of the cheddar.
So we can see that at the same speed,
the cheddar has more kinetic energy
because it has more mass.
But when the Swiss has a speed
of four meters per second
and the cheddar still has a
speed of two meters per second,
the Swiss's kinetic energy is
now 1/2 times .05 kilograms
times four meters per second
squared, which is .4 Joules.
So now, the kinetic energy of the Swiss
is twice the kinetic
energy of the cheddar.
So we can see that even though
the cheddar has more mass
the Swiss has more kinetic energy
because it's going faster.
In summary, kinetic energy
is the motion energy of an object.
The equation for kinetic
energy is 1/2 M V squared.
So as mass increases,
kinetic energy increases,
like the more massive
cheddar versus the Swiss,
and as velocity increases,
kinetic energy increases even more,
like the speedy Swiss
versus the slower cheddar.
Thanks for watching,
and I hope you learned a
little bit of something.